after the first short in which I showed  you some of the work done by students  that you can see at Milwaukee Institute  of Art and Design I thought I would show  you this next a little Book Nook you  could call it of student production now  my ad as a lot of people might not know  actually has a minor in book arts and so  this is the sort of stuff that you can  see students working on their cover art  in this case for all sorts of cool books  some of which exist some of which are  merely being projected or sketched out  so you can see all the stuff that they  produced in this class and this is  something that I think is particularly  cool  foreign